first up is cucumbers with ranch
seasoning with the person in the viral
video just takes it puts it in the
container and then gives it a good shake
shake shake really get all that flavor
around let's see oh well that's
delicious next one I am very excited for
it is ice cream wrapped inside of a
fruit roll-up I see no problems with
this I'm gonna scoop some ice cream
straight into here oh it's already
getting crispy ready for it
it's good
you're like forces you to bite the ice
cream and you get really bad brain food
the internet claims that taking chicken
nuggets and dipping them in a milkshake
is apparently delicious I have some
plant-based chicken nuggets here and
let's just find out it's a melted
milkshake
it's honestly not bad I remind you of
like dipping french fries in a milkshake